bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans sa vousourgarde ce
soir une mère et son fils qui essae de
se souvenir ensemble et le fils c'est
vous Claude askkolovic bonsoir merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir votre
mère evveline va nous rejoindre tout à
l'heure vous signez avec elle un très
beau récit chez Grasset à la fois sur ce
qu'elle a vécu ou dont elle se souvient
de son expérience des camp de
concentration et donc sur la mémoire
impossible mais aussi sur votre relation
très aimante et assez tumultueuse on en
parle tous les deux c'est intense dans
la deuxème partie notre grand débat ce
soir quel bilan de la tournée de Joe
Biden en Israël le président américain a
pesé pour que l'État hébreux débloque un
corridor humanitaire à Gaza mais après
la frappe sur l'hôpital dans le centre
de l'enclave palestinienne l'embrasement
régional menace nous en débattrons avec
les députés français qui reviennent tout
juste de l'État hébreux enfin nous
affranchi ce soir drôle d'époque la
chronique de Cécilia gabizon et puis
vous reprendrez bien un peu de 493 ce
sera dans Bourbon express avec El Mondin
Gava voilà pour le menu ce soir on y va
Claude askolovic ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant vous ne tomberez jamais les
mots de soutien à Israël de Joe Biden
sont très forts aujourd'hui mais pas
sans avertissement ne soyez pas consumés
par la rage a imploré le président
américain à benjamine netanahou alors
que retenir de cette visite quelles
conséquences sur la suite du conflit
bonsoir Benjamin Hadad bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance de Paris membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée et vous revenez d'un
déplacement dans l'État hébreux vous
êtes rendu quelques jours avec une
dizaine de députés vous êtes allé
notamment dans les kibuts où se sont
déroulés les les massacres du ramas on
va y revenir vous aussi vous revenez de
ce de ce déplacement en Israël
Pierre-Henri d Dumont bonsoir députés
les républicains du pas decalais vous
nous raconterez d'ailleurs on on va voir
un un reportage tout à l'heure sur sur
les images et et vos interlocuteurs
bonsoir général trincan Dominique
trinquan ancien chef de la mission
militaire française aux Nations Unies
votre dernier livre ce qui nous attend
l'effet papillon des conflits mondiaux
chez Robert Lafond voilà qui
nous réjouit d'avance enfin bonsoir
Vincent eugux bonsoir Miriam visage
familier de cette émission grand
reporter prof à Science Po et je
rappelle que vous avez couvert pour
L'Express ce conflit cette région
pendant des années inutile de préciser
que vous la connaissez vous aussi
cleaskolovic cette réion donc n'hésitez
pas à intervenir con je la connais
familialement ma sœur villab rovod j'ai
deux niè et un neveux une de mes nièes a
été rappelé bizarre c'est une gamine
elle est instructrice pour apprendre au
soldats à conduire des chars très
étrange par moment mais d'abord qu'a dit
Joe Biden on va voir ça tout de suite
avec Stéphan Blakowski c'est son chrono
tout de
suite allez je me retourne comme chaque
soir pour vous accueillir je vous invite
à faire pareil Claude bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir messieurs alors cette visite
américaine du président alors en se
rendant aujourd'hui en Israël Joe Bayen
avait deux objectifs en tête d'une part
réaffirmer son soutien sans faille à
Israël mais aussi tenter d'éviter une
escalade militaire qui risquerait
d'embraser l'ensemble de la région alors
pour ce qui est du soutien à Israël il a
été très clair on
l'écoute je voulais être ici pour une
raison simple je voulais que le peuple
d'Israël et les peuples du monde sachent
quelle est la position des
États-Unis en revanche pour ce qui est
de tenter d'apaiser la situation du
conflit ça se paraît beaucoup plus
difficile comme objectif d'autant plus
difficile depuis que vous le savez hier
soir une explosion a eu lieu dans un
hôpital à Gaza qui a coûté la viille et
à des centaines de Palestiniens vous le
savez sans doute le Hamas et Israël se
rejetteent la responsabilité du carnage
Israël dit que c'est une roquette
défectueuse de djihad islamique qui
s'est abattu sur l'hôpital tandis que le
Hamas accuse Israël d'avoir visé
délibérément cet hôpital alors le
président Macron lui est resta prudent
il a dit qu'il attendait que la lumière
soit faite le président Biden lui a
choisi son camp on
l'écoute je suis profondément attristé
et indigné par l'explosion de l'hôpital
de Gaza
hier et d'après ce que j'ai vu il semble
que cela a été fait par l'autre camp pas
par vous alors ça c'était ce matin le
président se rallé une version
israélienne depuis il a dit que ce sont
des données américaines qui avaient même
permis de confirmer cette version
israélienne et pour autant il n'a pas
réussi à convaincre la plupart des pays
arabes et musulmans qui considère que la
responsabilité dans d'Israël est engagée
donc le résultat c'est que alors que le
président Biden avait prévu de se rendre
en Jordanie cet après-midi pour
rencontrer le roi de Jordanie le
président égyptien l'Autorité
palestinienne et bien regardez la voyage
a été la visite a été annulée par la
Jordanie qui est pourtant un allié des
américains ils ont des accords de
défense avec les amériqu mais faut dire
que les leaders des pays arabes
s'inquiètent un peu de la mobilisation
de leur population dans les rues c'est
déjà le cas vous allez voir c'est arrivé
en Tunisie c'est arrivé en Liban c'est
arrivé dans différents pays en Tunisie
par exemple il y a même pas d'ambassade
d'Israël donc la foule en colère s'est
rassemblé
devant France devant l'ambassade de
France donc dans ce contexte c'est
évidemment difficile pour Biden dev
vrait pour un apaisement surtout
qu'évidemment l'Iran on le sait mais
régulièrement de l'huile sur le feu en
menaçant de déclencher un conflit
régional si Israël s'en prenait avec une
opération de grande envergure à la bande
de Gaza alors est-ce que ces menaces
iraniennes pourraient euh reconsidérer
l'idée d'une grosse attaque terrestre
sur Gaza euh on ne sait pas cette
opération se fait attendre en tout cas
ce matin euh le président américain a
rappelé son soutien à Israël mais il a
aussi demandé à ce que les opérations
militaires tiennent compte de la
population civile dans
l'écoute nous continuerons à soutenir
Israël dans ses efforts pour défendre
son peuple nous continuerons à
travailler avec vous et avec nos
partenaires dans toute la région pour
éviter que d'autres tragédies ne
frappent des civils innocents
j'ajouteraiis juste que les Israéliens
ont décidé vous l'avez dit Miriam
d'ouvrir la frontière avec l'Égypte pour
permettre l'entrée de l'aide humanitaire
sans doute un effet de la visite de
Biden voilà pour un résumé des faits
place aux experts pour l'analyse merci
beaucoup Stéphane benjamadad on le voit
la vague de colère dans le monde arabe
est importante aujourd'hui contre Israël
mais pas seulement contre les alliés
occidentaux il y a l'ambassade d'Israël
en Jordanie qui a été attaqué on voyait
ce qui se passe à Tunis devant
l'ambassade française est-ce que Joe
Biden n'a pas pris un risque
inconscidéré directement en s'appuyant
sur la version israélienne après après
le les fra frappe meurtrière sur
l'hôpital à Gaza déjà Joe Biden il est
venu en Israël pour apporter son soutien
est qu'il a appelé son soutien
indéfectible à Israël après une attaque
absolument atroce et sans précédent dans
l'histoire d'Israël une attaque
terroriste qui a tué 1400 israéliens
donc plus de 1000 civils dans des
conditions barbares on le sait et donc
les États-Unis tout comme d'ailleurs la
diplomatie française ont apporté leur
soutien à Israël qui a le droit de se
défendre contre le terrorisme après il
avait deux autres objectifs l'un c'est
en effet d'empêcher une escalade
régionale emraisement régional et
notamment on le sait les Américains ont
déplacé deux porte-avion en Méditerranée
orientale et font passer des messages de
dissuision très clair à l'Iran et l'Iran
et ses partenaires dans la région a
commencé par le hzbollah au Liban au
nord d'Israël donc ça c'est le deuxième
objectif vous trouvez que pour le moment
c'est dissuasif entre les mots de
soutien assez inconditionnel et voilà le
le choix le choix de militaire des giga
porte-avion vous pensez que le risque
d'embrasement malgré la colère dans les
rues est est contenu tout en tout cas
c'est c'est un objectif c'est un
objectif que nous partageons mais ça
dépend aussi bien sûr du des acteurs sur
le terrain et le troisème objectif
c'était d'avoir des engagement
humanitaire de la part d'Israël les
Israéliens ont annoncé aujourd'hui
effectivement ouvrir un corridor
humanitaire par le couloir de au de Joe
Biden en tout cas la diplomatie he ça a
été des messages qui ont été passés par
l'Europe et par les États-Unis après sur
la question de de l'hôpital pr alorsah
la France a été prudente hier dès le
début et d'ailleurs heureusement que la
France a été prudente parce qu'on a vu
des réactions qui ont tout de suite
attribué ce bombardement à Israël donc
la France a été prudente a demandé
d'abord il faut rappeler quand même
qu'il y a des civils qui sont morts et
donc rappeler notre solidarité avec les
les les civils notre compassion mais il
faut faire la lumière sur les événements
moi ce que je constate c'est que dès
hier soir on avait des sources qu'on
appelle Open Source intelligence qui
avait fait de la géolocalisation du
missile qui ont été repris par beaucoup
de journalistes sérieux aux États-Unis
comme en France qui considèrent qu'en
effet c'est un missile du Djihad
islamique qui serait retombé ou des
débris d'un missile qui serait retombé
sur le parking de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
Joe Biden affirme que des sources
américaines il
Donis dire juste que il faut on va dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines c'est déjà le cas faire face à
une guerre des images à beaucoup de
désinformation de propagande et donc il
faut être extrêmement prudent il faut
être prudent aussi quand on reprend les
chiffres il y a beaucoup de victimes
civiles mais les chiffres qu'on entend
aujourd'hui à Gaza ce sont les chiffres
qui sont communiqués par le Hamas pasour
internationau à gaz totalitaire
aujourd'hui sur la bande de Gaza et qui
prend en otage la population
palestinienne et qui utilise les
Palestiniens aussi comme des boucliers
humains on sait aujourd'hui que le Hamas
empêche les civils palestiniens qui le
souhaitent de partir vers le sud en
prenant par exemple les clés de voiture
alors que l'Israélien ont demander aux
Palestiniens du nord de la bande de Gaza
de pouvoir partir avant de détruire les
infrastructures les tunnels les armes du
Hamas on va on va avancer mais on va
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut tirer
comme
bilan de la visite de Biden c'est quand
même la première puissance mondiale sur
le plan militaire notamment g trin déjà
sur l'hôpital est-ce que vous pouvez
nous nous dire que les les images qui
sont produites par l'État hébreux euh
permettent d'identifier la provenance
des des tirs est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce qu'on sait vérifier les choses à
partir d'image aujourd'hui alors on sait
vérifier à partir d'images maintenant
les images actuelles sont pas
suffisantes mais elles permettent
effectiv de dire moi les images que j'ai
vu c'est plutôt l'extérieur le parking
qui a été tapé pas l'hôpital lui-même
premier point deème point l'image qui
consiste à voir un un missile qui est
détruit en fait et qui retombe et donc
des débris qui retombe et une explosion
importante je rappelle que le Hamas
utilise les hôpitaux pour mettre des
stocks d'armes et que donc des stocks de
mission peuvent exploser à partir du
moment ils sont touchés par des débris
incandescents de de ces missiles ça
c'est c'est la première chose deème
chose c'est qu'il y a les deux sources
il y a ces sources qu'on connaît et les
sources présentées par le président
Biden mais qui sont pas montré sont les
images
satellitaires vous vous doutez bien
qu'il y a des satellites américains qui
regardent tout ça de très près c'est
pour ça que le département de la Défense
américain aujourd'hui dit que selon ses
propres sources voilà selon ses propres
sources le problème c'est diffuser des
images de satellit américains ça prend
un peu de temps parce que lorsque vous
diffusez ces images vous avez des
sources sur ce qu'est le satellite
d'accord amériain veulent pas le montrer
donc on saura dans les jours qui VI on
saura mais juste de points
catastrophique c'est que ça arrive
vraiment au c'est le pire
contexte ça empêche la Réunion d'Aman
qui était absolument importante et
aujourd'hui quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on
dise la rue arabe toute façon accusera
Israël on peut apporter toutes les
preuves qu'on veut j'allais dire c'est
parti et Israël va être accusé Vincent
eug c'est le pire contexte il y a quand
même ce corridor il faut expliquer c'est
probablement quand même le poids des
Américains qui a permis l'ouverture par
Israël de de ce corridor qui que l'État
hébreu avait déjà bombardé avec la
frontière c'est bien ça égyptienne
Stéphane évoquait tout à l'heure le
double objectif alors réaffirmer la
solidarité inaltérable avec Israël c'est
fait le rempard dissuasif pour déjouer
le le spectre de l'embrasement régional
ça reste àouvé mais il y avait un
troisème objectif d'essayer de
convaincre le monde arabe que les
États-Unis pouvaiit être aussi en
quelque sorte le meilleur espoir pour
ménager des corridors humanitaires au
profil des civil corridors au demeurant
conditionnel hein euh Israël accepte la
chemin humanitaire vivre au médicaments
uniquement pour la population civile du
sud de la bande de Gaza et à précisé que
il n'y aurait pas de secours via Israël
tant que les otages n'auraient pas été
libéré euh le drame de cette affaire
parmi d'autres mais c'est une vérité
historique c'est que vous pourriez
démontrer d'une manière absolument
incontestable factuellement que par
exemple il s'agit bien d'une roquette
islamique ça ne suffirait pas on est
dans une manière tellement incandescente
que de toute façon pour effectivement ce
qu'on appelle par comité de langage qu m
fondamental que la vérité soit fa sur la
provenance de cette requette et j'ajoute
un dernier point mais qui est lié au au
précédent c'est que on mesure là encore
dans le meilleur des cas le yatus dans
le pire des cas pour eux le divorce
entre les exécutifs arabes qui ont
entrepris des démarche de normalisation
avec Israël voir qu'ils les ont
accomplis et puis la rue qui elle de
toute façon n'acceptera jamais quand
vous parcourez cette région du monde
vous rendez compte que y compris en
Égypte hein 1979 en Jordanie traité de
1994 et à forsuie en Arabie Saoudite
dans les pays du GO
les gens vous disent non pas
publiquement par crainte des
représailles de pouvoir généralement
autocratique mais que ils n'accepteront
jamais la normalisation avec ceux qu'ils
appellent dans leur lexique l'entité
sioniste Pierre-Henri Dumont vous
revenez d'Israël on va venir sur votre
déplacement dans dans un instant dans
dans la deuxième partie de ce ce débat
mais après tout est-ce que les
Israéliens que vous avez rencontré ne
doutaient pas du soutien américain
massif après tout netaniaou était très
proche de Donald Trump voir Joe Biden
dire ces mots-là avec 2 gig porte-avion
est-ce que ça les a surpris rassuré on
s'en doute mais surpris ou pas surpris
non je pense pas mais le message était
évidemment destiné aux Israéliens mais
pas que le message est surtout destiné
aux pays aux alentours en particulier à
l'Iran de ne pas activer ses proxis en
particulier le Hezbollah ça a été dit
dans dans la région pour éviter un
embrasement général de la région d'où la
présence des deux porte-avion à
proximité immédiate des côtes pour se
figurer les choses c'est c'est quoi
c'est 500 m avec avec une vingtaine
d'avions qui peivent contrôler l'espace
aérien d'Israël immédiatement c'est ça
parce que c'est c'est vraiment un
arsenal militaire mass parle de
porte-avion c'est pas de porte-avion
qu'on doit parler c'est de groupe
aéronaval groupe aéronaval vous avez des
fris de Gates anti-aériennne
antisous-marines vous avez les
sous-marins vous avez beaucoup
effectivement ça contrôle une zone
importante je je vous en prie poursuivez
c'est pour la précision et c'est vrai
vous avez parfaitement raison c'est pas
que les porortes-avions c'est l'ensemble
des navires qui accompagne parceil faut
ravitailler il faut protéger ou bien
porteavion parce que c'est un bâtiment
qui est extrêmement fragile et
vulnérable aux attaques extérieures donc
je je pense en tout cas que l'enjeu
était évidemment celui de rassurer la
population israélienne montrer aussi aux
autres pays à l'Iran en particulier
qu'il avait le le l'Oncle Sam qui était
derrière avec avec son son gros bâton et
qui était prêt à activer activer ce
qu'il devait activer si l'Iran rentrait
dans la danse directement ou
indirectement et en même temps le
président américain a eu cette petite
phrase qui n'est pas passée inaperçu
écoute
la justice doit être rendue mais je vous
mets en garde si vous ressentez de la
rage ne vous laissez pas envahir par
elle après le 11 septembre nous étions
enragés aux États-Unis nous avons
cherché à obtenir justice et nous
l'avons obtenu mais nous avons aussi
commis des erreurs Benjamin Hadad ne pas
répéter les erreurs américaines d'après
le 11 septembre vous revenez d'Israël
vous avez parlé aux gens à des soldats
deal peut-être même desogradés est-ce
que que cette rage est-ce que cet esprit
de vengeance les anime est-ce qu'ils
peuvent entendre au contraire le message
la qui les implore du président
américain moi je n'ai pas entendu de
rage mais un désir légitime de sécurité
l'Israëlien on été frappé dans des
conditions atroces et d'ailleurs il faut
le préciser les kibuts que nous avons
visité le concert pour la paix c'était
derniers rest de l'utopie pacifiste de
la gauche israélienne c'est des kibuts
qui sont à 2 km de Gaza où des
Palestiniens venaient régulièrement
travaill c'est pas des colons c'est pas
des territoires occupés euh et et et
c'est vrai que la quand on quand on
rapporte à la population israélienne le
nombre de morts chaque famille est uillé
et et et celles qui ne sont pas
directement en voit aujourd'hui des
soldats ou des réservistes donc toute la
société a été frappée dans le la pire
journée de de barbarie de l'histoire
d'Israël Israël a droit de se défendre
Israël Dr mais on est tous au bord de la
Bime là sur à redouter un bain de sang
complet à Gaza en casofensive terrest
parce que vous voyez d'ailleurs que
l'Israélien attendent depuis quelques
jours avant de mener l'offensive
terrestre ont demandé aux civils de de
partir je crois c'est c'est le
contraire vous savez il y a pas de
solution possible sans une solution
politique à deux états sans la
séparation je parle pas forcément de
paix parce que je crois plus à la paix
avec des embrassades mais la séparation
des des Palestiniens il a pas de
solution politique possible avec le
Hamas avec le Hamas au pouvoir qui prend
en otage la population palestinienne de
la bande de Gaza avec le Hamas qui a une
idéologie génocidaire islamiste une
charte qui demande la destruction
d'Israël et c'était bien l'objectif de
de cette attaque de la la semaine
dernière et donc Israël a non seulement
le droit de se défendre mais a le droit
de poursuivre comme objectif
l'éradication du terrorisme du Hamas en
respectant évidemment le droit
international humanitaire mais que le
Hamas tout de même il faut rappeler et
le premier à violer en se cachant en
cachant des armes en cachant des
combattants parmi les civils mais effec
il faut que cette se fasse dans le cadre
du droit interagresseur est très très
clairement le ramas qui a commis des
actes don on a du mal à qualifier
aujourd'hui de vouz intervenir Claude
ascolov qu'est-ce que vous redoutez le
plus le premier jour immédiatement après
l'attaque c'est mon boulot à la presse
de France Inter dire les journaux le
plus grand journal israélien en tout cas
par son autorité morale à Harz disait
que ce qui s'était passé il racontait
toutes les atrocités ne donnez pas
licence à la vengeance ne donz pas
licence au pouvoir israélien de de de de
faire des des crimes des crimes de
guerre c'est le mot qui éta employé dans
l'éditorial de Hartz encore une fois
grand journal israélien lié par son
correspondant militaire au haut gradé
c'est pas du tout un journal de
gauchiste c'est un journal qui incarne
une permanence israélienne ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que le couple qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure Biden et nitanahou fa
regardz l'autre celui qui ne disait rien
Benjamin nitanianou n'est arrivé au
pouvoir que pour détruire le processus
de paix qui avait été enclenché à
l'époque des accords d'usl entre Rabine
perz et Arafat paix à leur âme à tous
les trois il a fait sa carrière
là-dessus de manière méthodique au
moment où le Hamas a envoyé ses tueurs
terrifiés massacrés dans le sud d'Israël
les trouples israéliennes étaient en
train de protéger des extrémistes colons
qui tuent régulièrement qui terrorisent
des Palestiniens C Jordanie voilà ils
étaient là-bas pour protéger conqu ce
que dire s'il y a des colères en Israël
et il y a j'en suis témoin dans ma
propre famille qui sont vous m'entendez
parler vous devinez à quel camp on va
dire culturel je me réfère sœur depuis
qu'elle est parti qu'elle a décidé de
vivre en Israël a toujours voté pour les
partis de la gauche sioniste c'est une
constante je la vois aujourd'hui blessée
parce qu'elle a vécu dans un kibou du
sud d'Israël blessé touché dans une
colère inédite dans ce sens-là le Hamas
a exactement réussi dans son opération
transformer ce pays mais à côté de ça
l'autre colère qui existe et qui est
immense c'est celle qui est dirigée
contre un dirigeant nationaliste au
demeurant corrompu qui gouverne le pays
avec l'extrême droite et qui la gouverne
mal et
et quand B dies de mois de manifestation
contre
benamé céit pas à la rage ça dit quelque
chose aussi de l'état de la société du
pouvoir et de l'État israélien
aujourd'hui c'est une des grandes
tristesses évidemment il y a pas de paix
possible avec le Hamas mais il n'y a pas
non plus de construction politique
possible avec ce qui s'est fabriqué en
Israël ces dernières années très bien je
vous ramène à Joe Biden et au moment on
verra si netanahou a encore une survie
politique possible beaucoup considèrent
qu'il est déjà mort sur le point le plan
politique offensive terrestre général
trincan qu'on nous disait imminente qui
ne cesse d'être retardé pour quelle
raison est-ce que Joe Biden a pu peser
dans le fait que les les soldats doivent
temporiser ou au contraire il y a des
vrais problèmes logistiques à régler non
alors le premier problème c'est
qu'effectivement les Américains
retiennent le bras de du gouvernement
netaniaahou et netianao comme vous le
disiez il est mort donc sur le plan
politique il est on l'envoie serrer les
mains des soldats sur le front ça fait
un peu de de Come mais c'est Biden qui
prend contact avec marmou Abbas et qui
monte le sommet qui malheureusement a
été annulé à Aman si vous voulez et le
le le rappel du 11 septembre doit nous
frappé le 11 septembre tout le monde
était autour des États-Unis en disant
c'est une catastrophe tout le monde les
Russes les Chinois tout le monde était
autour d'eux 2003 les 3/4s de la planète
étai contre l'offensive et 3/4 de la
planète derrière la France j'étais à New
York à ce moment-là était
derrière et là c'est pareil le 7 octobre
tout le monde est derrière Israël en
disant c'est absolument catastrophique
ce qui s'est passé et là on retient
parce que il ne faut pas qui est bien
sûr à payer au droit de la guerre et
cetera et ca alors cette offensive mais
l'offensive terrestre est-ce qu'elle est
inévitable alors ça me paraît difficile
aujourd'hui de ne pas aller alors moi je
prends pas les termes de monsieur
netanahou qui est d'éradiqué le Hamas se
passera pas comme ça mais de casser
l'infrastructure du Hamas qui est tout à
fait autre chose et ça casser
l'infrastructure du Hamas l'armée peut
le faire aussi bien par les
bombardements que par des raides à
l'intérieur mais maintenant pas
d'occupation le président Biden l'a
rappelé pas d'occupation faut pas rester
trop longtemps et puis ça ne va pas
éradiquer le Hamas le Hamas qui est ça
TR très bien rappelé est est d'une
certaine façon un outil qui a été qui a
été élevé par par la politique de
Monsieur N c'est aussi une force en soi
j'ai lu un excellent reportage dans le
monde où des officiers israéliens
parlaient qui disaient ces gens-là le
Hamas nous attendent depuis des années
la grande surprise israélienne c'est
aussi la capacité guerrière des troupes
du Hamas pour massacrer des civils
c'était ignoble mais cette capacité
guerrière existe Israël a déjà eu ce
genre de surprise avec le hzbola et il
s'en souvienent Vincent je crois qu'il
faut se méfier de la dimension
incantatoire du mythe de l'éradication
éradiquer au sens étymologique ça veut
dire arracher la racine ça veut dire an
antir aussi la matrice et les causes or
qu'a dit netano le lendemain du grand
carnage du 7 octobre il a dit comme le
monde a détruit daesh nous allons
anéantir le Hamas ah bon le monde a
détruit daesh ça m'avait totalement
échappé je peux vous citer dans un
souffle 12 pays dans lesquels les
filiales de l'État islamique sont
actives et ravageuses mais vous
comprenez quand même après ce qui s'est
passé les massacre dans les quiboues
israël veut au moins en finir avec la
branche arm mais les organisateurs les
chefs c'est leur devoir c'est un
impératif pour eux mais je rappelle
simplement puisqu'on parlait de
porte-avion impressionnant et
spectaculaire tout à l'heure que c'est à
bord d'un porte-avion tout aussi
impressionnant et spectaculaire qu'un
certain George W Bush a prononcé la
formule
immémorial mission accompl à propos de
Al-Qaïda et du on a vu ce qu'il en
estevenu donc méfions-nous encore une
fois de ces serments intenables
benjaminad cette cette opération
terrestre j'imagine que vous en avez
éidemment parler avec vos interlocuteurs
là-bas est-ce qu'elle aura lieu parce
qu'on peut lire il y a il y a certaines
sources au sein d're salle qui disent
qu'il y a peut-être d'autres scénarios
possibles est-ce que c'est c'est une
erreur d'imaginer ce scénario là
alternative elle aura lieu pour vous je
je je ne sais pas pour être tout à fait
franc je pense qu'il y a une volonté
très claire de d'aller essayer de
frapper le plus durement possible et
éradiquer le Hamas moi j'entends
effectivement sur daesh je pense pour
autant que la coalition internationale a
frappé très durement daesh en Syrie et
en Irak euh très durement à Mossou à
raka avec des résultats qui ont été
probants bien sûr que à la fois le
terrro idéologique et des cellules
existent dans d'autres pays de la région
mais bien sûr c'est une réalité et notre
vigilance face au terrorisme elle n'a
jamais faibli on a fait que renforcer
d'ailleurs les moyens des services de
renseignement intérieur extérieur ces
ces dernières années on déjoue
régulièrement des attentats sur le
territoire français mais il y a eu une
roste occidentale après les attentats
horribles que nous avions connu en
2014-215 on pense au Bataclan évidemment
il y a un parallèle qui est évident avec
la rave partie en en Israël Pierre-Henri
Dumont vous vouliez rajouter quelque
chose sinon je passe tout de suite le
reportage sur votre sur la question de
l'intervention de de tsal dans la bande
de Gaza la question c'est qu'ils savent
pas très bien ce à quoi ils vont devoir
s'attendre également et que vous
imaginez bien que quand euh vous avez
subi une telle attaque le 7 octobre et
les jours suivants parce que c'est pasê
que le 7 octobre que vous avez été pris
parfaitement par surprise et avec le
degré de barbarie qui a été celui des
militants du Hamas quand vous allez
envoyer des jeunes conscrits ou des
personnes qui sont rappelés dans des
tunnels qui sont probablement piégés
avec on peut imaginer par exemple des
corps qui sont qui sont piégés par le
Hamas c'est pas une partie de plaisir et
que donc l'enjeu c'est évidemment
d'éviter un BAT de sang des civils mais
également un B de sang des militaires
qui sont pour la plupart des civils qui
ont été rappelés sous les drapeaux et
l'hypothèse d'otage comme avec
l'hypothèse d'otage qui qui est
évidemment présente et avec euh la
volonté qui est très clair très affichée
dans quasiment toutes les couches de la
société israélienne d'éradiquer pardon
de reprendre ce terme le Hamas parce que
la question c'est qu'ils savent très
bien que ils ne pourront plus coexister
avec le Hamas à côté et la difficulté
qu'il y a c'est que derrière on remplace
par quoi parce que l'Autorité
palestinienne aujourd'hui est une
Autorité palestinienne incarnée par
marbouabas qui est grabataire corrompu
qui verse l'Autorité palestinienne ce
mois prochain 3 3 million de dollars aux
familles des meurtriers des assassins du
Hamas pour les remercier d'avoir fait ce
qu'ils ont fait donc on voit bien qu'il
y a pas les bons d'un côté et les ma
alors justement on va essayer de
partager quelques images certaines vous
les avez rapporté grâce à des vidéos à
des petits films de vos de vos
téléphones portables c'est un reportage
de Marco Pomier donc une dizaine de
députés se sont rendus dans l'État
hébreux ils sont rentrés ce soir même
regardez
la visite a débuté par une vision
d'horreur dans le camp militaire de
Choura des containires réfrigérés et
alligné pour entreposer 327 cadavres de
civils israéliens des corps brûlés
défigurés au-delà du reconnaissable le
travail d'identification est difficile
mais indispensable pour les familles
sans nouvelles de leurs proches dans
leur journal de bord les députés
témoignent femmes des enfants ont été tu
des mamans ont été éventrées des femmes
ont été violées quel que soit leur âge
c'est un massacre innommable les 10
parlementaires français constatent aussi
la barbarie AK faraza l'un des premiers
kibuts attaqué par les terroristes du
Hamas ici 69 personnes sont mortes des
témoignages de soldats qui ont retrouvé
de nombreux corps décapité y compris des
enfants à seel-là qui nous a dit que il
s'excusait de ne pas avoir pris la photo
d'un bébé décapité parce que jamais il
n'aurait cru qu'on ne le croirait pas et
les stigmates de la violence sont encore
visible maison brûlées mur criblé de
balles au sol dans ce salon une marre de
sang séchée l'odeur de la mort est
encore présente racontent les députés
nous avons découvert un nouvel aadours
sur glan dit François Cormier bouligon
visite éprouvante pour ses
parlementaires à 2 km seulement de la
bande de Gaza N a demandé pour des RA de
sécurité de mettre le gilet par bal le
casque on entend au loin les
missil la guerre est réelle encore ici
des députés bouleversés aussi par les
témoignag des familles des victimes et
d'otage un moment déchirant comme
rarement explique Carl olive sur les
réseaux
sociaux pour la première fois benjaminad
il a une vidéo d'une age Franco elenne
qui a 21 ans qui s'appelle Mia elle a
été blessée au bras ses parents ont pris
la parole hier en Israël vous vous les
avez rencontrés j'imagine avec vos
collègues ces familles d'otage français
sur place donc quelle ét sont-il dans
quel enfer vivent-il c'est un enfer il
vivait un cauchemar ça fait une dizaine
de jours qu'ils ont perdu des parents
des enfants souvent très jeunes parfois
des bébés des maris parfois des familles
entières qui ont disparu alors disparu
parce que il y a plus de 300 corps qui
n'ont toujours pas pu être identifiés
parce qu'ils ont été brûlés au-delà de
ce qu'il est possible de reconnaître et
il y en a évidemment qui sont
aujourd'hui détenus au Tage plus de 200
en tout et quelques français par le
Hamas à à Gaza ils veulent qu'on les
aide la diplomatie français alors bon
vous savez qu'on est on doit être le
président de la République l'a dit
aujourd'hui on doit être très discret
sur les tractation diplomatique en cours
on exige la libération de ces otages
sans conditions il y a des tractations
diplomatiques ils sont tous en contact
avec le consulat de France à à Jérusalem
dès qu'on a des des preuves de vie des
informations on leur transmet et
l'objectif évidemment c'est une priorité
absolue c'est de libérer ses otages ce
sont des compatriotes et on ne les
oublie pas et c'est le message qu'avec
Pierre-Henri Dumont et les autres
députés on est venu leur passer on est
venu aussi écouter et je crois qu'on a
tous été très admiratif de de leur
dignité de leur courage dans cette
épreuve je crois même que vous vous
étiez à une réunion en présence de de
parents d'enfants kidnappés au Tage et
et un de ses parents a dû sortir à la
demande de de tsal et il apprenait la
mort de de son enfant c'est ça ouais je
rejoins ce que dit Benjamin dad ce qui
ce qui reste de cette rencontre c'est la
dignité avec laquelle les parents les
proches des des disparus parce que la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si les
personnes les familles sont aotage ou
décédés et vous l'avez dit lors de cette
réunion un papa est parti subitement il
a reçu un coup de téléphone et c'était
l'armée qui lui annonçait avoir réussi à
identifier le le le corps de sa fille et
de la même façon on avait la la famille
de Karine journau qui était présente et
hier soir le le corps de de cette jeune
fille a été identifié également parmi
les
327 corps que nous avons pu voir dans la
première base dont vous avez pu
présenter les les images faut bien
comprendre la barbarie avec laquelle les
les terroristes islamistes ont frappés
ils ont groupé des corps par quatre ou 5
parfois par 10 pour les brûler les
rendre inidentifiables euh et et donc
au-delà de la question de savoir sur
glan l'image vous semble approprié oui
quand on était dans le kibut c'était
exactement ça c'était la vie c'était
gelé euh les vélos étaient par terre les
les ballons étai étai par terre il y
avait une maison où vous voyez ce que
disait Benjamin c'est un kibutz qui
était un kibutz idéaliste il y avait des
des ouvriers de Gaza qui venaient il y a
18000 ouvriers de Gaza qui chaque jour
avait des permis de travail journalier
pour venir travailler dans la région
proche de Gaza et et vous aviez à
l'entrée de cette maison un panneau qui
où cétait écrit en anglais welcome we
are friends et ils ont été décimés ils
ont été absolument décimés
méthodiquement et quand les familles
n'arrivaient pas à rentrer dans les
chambres fortes chaque maison est
équipée d'une chambre forte les
terroristes mettaient le feu à la maison
pour les Brû les vif h et et donc il y
avait en effet cette odeur de mort qui
flottait qui imprégnait le vêtement nos
narines et c'était absolument terrible
et ce ce récit du soldat vous l'avez
mentionné dans le sujet sur les bébés
décapités il faut faire le travail de
journaliste sur les informations mais il
y a quelque chose d'obsène dans cette
polémique sur les images et et qui vous
dit je regrette de ne pas avoir
photographier mexcuse ouais je m'excuse
ouais il dit c'était en fait les soldats
qui nous ont accompagné sont ceux qui
ont libéré ces kibibuts parce que comme
le dit Pierre Henri aujourd'hui c'estes
quiiboues sont vides la ville de Sderot
aussi 40000habitants a été complètement
vidé le sud d'Israël est fantôme parce
qu'il y a les roquettes qui tombent et
donc il y a 500000 israéliens à peu près
qui sont réfugiés aujourd'hui dans le
reste du pays et et donc on a parlé avec
ces soldats et ce soldat a tenu dans ses
bras un bébé décapité il nous a dit je
m'excuse de ne pas avoir pris de photo
parce que jamais j'aurais pu imaginer
qu'on ne me croirait pas et c'est vrai
qu'on a vu cette polémique
obsène sur le nombre de j'ose à peine en
parler mais le nombre de bébés décapités
peut-être que certains ont été tués
d'une autre façon mais mais c'est une
horreur comme s'il n'y en avait pas eu
alors ça relativisait l'ensemble des
massacres un tout petit mot rapidement
puis je voudrais terminer avec le
général Trincant il y a une constante de
de dans l'antisémitisme on a souvent dit
que le conflit israopastinen était
impréé d'antisémitisme c'est souvent
faux là en l'occurrence il y a une
constante c'est la profanation du corps
des Juifs ça renvoie au pogrome de
l'Empire russe ça renvoie au bébé
fracassé ça renvoie au traitement qui
exercit les nazis ça ne veut pas dire
que le Hamas et le nazisme et cetera ça
veut dire simplement que dans la psychée
israélienne dans la compréhension de
gens comme ceux de ma familleou dans la
mienne il y a quelque chose qui relève
de la très très longue histoire s'agit
pas de prise de Tage de tuer les
Israéliens tuent et tuent énormément et
autant nous sommes capables nous en
Occident de nous identifier à des
familles tuées dans leur village autant
nous avons plus de mal et c'est un
problème à nous identifier à des gens
qui tombent dans dans les gravades de
leur immeuble à Gaza ou ailleurs c'est
un gros problème nous identifier des
paysans palestiniens en S Jordanie qui
sont terrifiés par les colons mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça dans la très très
longue histoire juive qui se poursuit
par Israël mais pas seulement cette idée
que le corps du Juif peut-être
absolument profané
démembré brûlé profané là ça dit quelque
chose et je connais pas les intentions
du Hamas à Dieu ne PLA que je les
connaisse mais je sais que faisant cela
euh le Hamas a très profondément ébranlé
la société israëline pas seulement en
terme de vengeance mais à quoi sert ce
pays ce pays était inventé ù le sionisme
a été inventé à l'époque des pogrom de
l'Empire russe à la fin du 19e siècle on
y est ex on est exactement dans la même
configuration allez je vous donne deux
mots de conclusion rapidement oui je
suis fondamentalement d'accord sur
l'image du pogrom il il y a quelque
chose d'autre qui m'a beaucoup frappé
dans ce qu'on a entendu dans les 327
corps qui n'ont pas été identifiés il y
a deux raisons la principale raison
c'est que certains sont impossible à
identifier parce qu'ils ont été
totalement brûlé il y a aussi des
familles entières qui ont été décimées
et donc plus personne ne vient réclamer
les cors les enfants PES enfants vous ê
r ça m'a ça m'a fait penser en fait à à
la Choa c'està-dire que vous avez des
familles entières il y a pas une victime
ou deux et donc plus personne ne vient
même réclamer le le corps des victimes
vous êtes allé dans ce site prêt la vie
vous sont entreposés dans des container
réfrigérés les corps qui sont en en
cours d'identification on imagine voilà
ce que ça a dû vous coûter un mot de de
conclusion quand quand on revient au mot
de Biden qui parle encore de solution à
deux états après ça dans combien de
temps on pourra se reparler mais parce
qu'il faut un espoir il faut travailler
avec une espérance on en parler avant
que on prenne le le micro il faut qu'il
y ait une espérance s'il y a pas
d'espérance c'est une catastrophe donc
on doit travailler dans sens-l mais
deuxième mot que je voulais dire c'est
qu' on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui de
cette crise épouvantable du Moyen-Orient
on parle moins de la crise en Ukraine et
pourtant il y a des liens avec tout ça
il y a des liens parce que Moscou on l'a
vu à a refusé une une résolution au
Conseil de sécurité parce que on
naccusait pas assez donc la le monde est
réellement en train de changer il change
en Europe il change au Moyen-Orient et
il y a des liens importants je rappelle
que théran est allié avec Moscou est
allié avec Pékin le président Poutine
est à Pékin actuellement et tout ceci
fait partie de ces grands changements du
monde les les battement d'elles l'ffet
papillon des conflits mondiaux merci on
s'arrête là merci à vous d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Claude askkolovic dans une dizaine de
minutes les affanchis ce soir pour leur
parti prix elles sont deux Cécilia
gabidon qui va revenir sur ses empathies
sélectives après euh le conflit Israël
aupalestinien et surtout l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard et puis euh vous
reprendrez bien un peu de de 493 on
verra ça avec Elsa mondingava mais
d'abord on va plonger euh dans votre
livre ce souvenir ensemble chez Grasset
ça raconte à de voix les mémoires
éclatées d'une famille la vôtre celle
d'une mère et celle de son fils Claude
ascolovic regardez l'invitation de
elsamond dingava et puis on accueille
Eveline askolovic juste
après si on vous invite Eveline et
Claude askkolovic c'est pour parler de
la mémoire de la Choa et du rôle de
témoin mais on était loin de si imaginez
que votre livre entrerait à ce point en
résonance avec l'actualité en Israël les
souvenirs de ce que l'on appelle parfois
avec une grande pudeur les heures les
plus sombres de l'histoire ont ressurgi
ces dernières semaines la Choa c'est
justement le sujet de votre livre
Eveline et Claude askolovic un livre à
deux voix et à quatre mains vous Eveline
l' déporté à 4 ans qui dans son camp de
concentration décrète j'ai fermé la
porte de ma mémoire pour pour survivre
vous Claude le journaliste qui confesse
j'ai appris la Choa sans ma famille
Eveline a été déportée très jeune a
décidé après n'avait pas eu le choix
parce qu'elle avait très peu de
souvenirs de laisser ça derrière elle
mais ça dégageit un rayonnement d'une
intensité ma sur et moi savions que
maman avait été déportée mais elle ne
nous en parlait pas et elle était
habitée par ça c'est parce que pour moi
c'était pas arrivé c'était pas moi moi
je n'avais pas été une victime de guerre
c'était mes parents on n'en parlait pas
toute ma génération n'en a jamais parlé
et puis un jour c'est sorti alors il a
fallu trouver les clés pour ouvrir la
mémoire la parole l'écoute dans la
tendresse et les disputes qui peuvent
exister entre une mère et son fils car
Claude vous avez vu votre mère se
transformer peu à peu en témoin Éveline
vous avez décidé de raconter au
collégiens au lycéens pour que personne
ne puisse dire que cela n'avait pas
existé alors à l'heure où l'on reparle
de pogrom Evelin
askolovic quels sentiments vous ont
traversé après les massacres du 7
octobre Eveline askkolovic déjà bonjour
merci de nous avoir rejoint pour
répondre à cette question forcément quel
est quel sentiment comment avez-vous
réagi au début je faisais pas du tout le
rapport avec la Choa c'était des
massacres et puis petit à petit quand
même on n échappe pas parce que j'ai un
problème avec les enfants et les enfants
je je sais que moi j'ai été mise dans
des camps pour une seule raison parce
que j'étais juive et là le massacre des
enfants parce que des enfants ont été
massacrés m'a forcément fait penser à
moi-même à la Choa
et perturbant Eveline askolovic vous
êtes né à Amsterdam il y a 85 ans dans
une famille juive vous aviez 4 ans quand
les Allemands sont venus vous cherchez
vous êtes avez été déporté avec vos
parents d'abord dans des camps
hollandais puis à Bergen bellsen en
Allemagne et après ça vous n'avez pas pu
parler vous n'avez pas pu parler à
Claude et à myiam vos enfants quand ils
étaient petits pourquoi ce n'était pas
possible de leur parler à ce moment-là
pour vous parce qu'on ne parlait pas
toute ma
génération n'a pas parlé parce
que quelque part on se sentait pas
concerné j'étais dans après la guerre
j'étais dans une école juive où on était
41 élèves dans une école juive et tous
tous tous avaient été soit dans des
camps soit cachés soit dans un dans un
getto et on en a jamais parlé parce que
parce qu'on en a pas parlé on trouvait
pas c'était quelque chose qui nous était
pas mais le fait d'avoir été déporté si
petite à 4 ans est-ce que ça ne vous a
pas au fond empêché de vous autoriser
tout simplement à vous reconnaître comme
une rescapé des camp non parce que c'est
très compliqué à expliquer et quand je
vais dans des école ils ne comprennent
pas toujours ça n'avait vraiment pas
existé pour
et pour vos parents et parce que on
savait que les parents avaient été dans
des camp mes parents é
déportés à un tel point quand ma mère
est décédée en 2019 dans la religion
juive il y a une semaine de deuil et il
y a des gens qui viennent à la maison et
on sonne à la porte je suis là j'ouvre
la porte il y a un monsieur qui est là
je dit bonjour vous êtes qui il me dit
je
suiser
pu je le regarde j'ai dit tu es le petit
y pi hache sur ma photo de classe parce
que j'amène partout ma photo de classe
de cette classe
CM1 et il a dit ben oui et puis on
s'assoit là à côté de l'autre et je lui
dis et toi tu as été où pendant la
guerre et il dit j'étais à Bergen benzen
ah je dis ah bon mais mais moi aussi et
il me dit oui mais toi tu es revenu avec
tes parents et moi je suis revenue sans
parents c'était à ce point-là on savait
que le petit yopiacher habitait chez une
tante mais le pourquoi non ça n'existait
pas il habitait chez une tante c'était
son étiquette vous vous l'avez attendu
longtemps cette parole de votre mère
quand vous étiez plus jeune et puis
quand elle arrive parce qu'il y a eu des
cauchemars des insomnies qui à l'âge de
50 ans Eveline askkolovic donc
tardivement ont déclenché un retour de
la parole et du témoignage mais vous
écrivez au fond vous l'avez attendu mais
quand elle arrive vous ne la souhaitez
plus pourquoi j'ai détesté le moment où
ma mère est devenue un un témoin euh je
déteste cette idée des témoins je
déteste les gens qui me disent on
voudrait inviter ta maman parce que
quand elle sera morte quand les gens de
sa génération seront morts on pourra
plus parler de la choix vous êtes
gentils mais le jour où ma maman n'est
plusâ serit triste pour elle-même pas
pour l'histoire
euh ma sœur et moi avons toujours su que
maman qu'Eveline avait été déportée on
savait on a jamais parlé quand j'étais
plus jeune tout seul
dans l'appartement dans la maison de mes
grands-parents au Pays-Bas qui était une
sorte de reconstitution d'une maison
allemande CIT des Juifs allemands à
Amsterdam j'ouvrais un vieil album photo
qui avait été cachée pendant la guerre
par une amie de de ma famille et je
regardais la dernière photo qui avait
été prise d'Éveline de ma maman juste
avant d'être déporté c'était
l'agrandissement d'une photo d'identité
et je pleurais tout seul dessus pig rien
je se demandais pour pourquoi j'étais
triste donc c'était ma manière de
rentrer en contact puis après la vie a
fait son œuvre ce qu'on a essayé de
faire ce qu'on a réussi un livre sur la
Choa c'est pas un livre sur c'est un
livre sur la mémoire éclaté c'est un
livre sur ce que ça nous a fait toi
maman de de voir la mémoire de la
famille être prise par ma grand-mère qui
était une petite femme de fer qui a
sauvé sa famille dans les camps et qui
après saparé
le et moi et moi qui un jour qui avait
une maman normale qui c'est M témoigné
je n'y comprenais rien je détestais ça
puis on a réussi à se parler enfin et
puis là je te laisse parler c'est-à-dire
ma mère euh moi j'ai commencé à avoir
des des des des cauchemars quand j'avais
50 ans et une nuit sans sommeil j'ai mis
les trois quatre souvenirs que j'avais
sur du papier et mon mari qui était
rédacteur en chef de l'arche l'a trouvé
au petit matin et il a dit je vais le je
vais le publier j'ai dit mais il y a
vraiment pas de quoi publier c'est pas
très intéressant et il a dit tu sais pas
tout le monde a eu 6 ans à Bergen Benson
et il l'a publié et à mon grand
soulagement personne a relevé dans mon
entourage parce que j'étais une battante
j'étais c'est pas que j'étais très connu
mais enfin j'étais en Union soviétique
j'étais une battante personne n relevé
et ma propre mère m'a téléphoné et elle
a dit c'est drôle que tu as écrit ça je
ne croyais pas que tu étais concerné et
elle m'a donné l'autorisation en
quelques sorte de ne pas être concerné
et j'étais très soulagée j'avais pas
besoin de me rappeler pas du tout je
continuais ma petite vie tranquille pas
cons et ça revient quand même et alors
on comprend pourquoi très bien dans
parce que c'est intéressant aussi c'est
un questionnement sur une relation sur
la manière dont cette mémoire est
transmise déjà la forme du livre ça ne
pouvait être que un récit à un chapitre
Claude un chapitre Eveline sous la plume
de Claude j'imagine mais chacun relie au
fur et à mesure chez tous les mots
d'Eveline sont les siens soit viennent
de nos disputes nombreuses soit viennent
d'un texte très beau qu'elle avait écrit
qui est en quelque sorte le prémise le
le le le l'avantexte de ce livre et tous
les mots sont les siens d'où vous est
venu l'idée de cette forme là alors pour
le coup oui quand j'ai renoncé quand
j'ai accepté la liberté de ma mère vous
ne vouliez pas l'interviewer c'était
impossible je me suis retrouvé avec
Eveline maman écrit un texte soumet un
éditeur mon ami Christophe bataille chez
Grasset il nous dit c'est bien mais
c'est pas ça faut que vous racontiez ça
ensemble elle ne le veut pas parce
qu'éveline en témoignant poursuit la
petite fille qu'elle était elle essaie
de rebondir sur le mur qui est fermé
quelques souvenirs qu' la hantre les
mêmes depuis des années elle cherche le
reste c'est tragique et c'est magnifique
et moi je ne veux pas de ça parce que
entre 1946 quand mes grands-parents et
ma mère sont rapatriés au Pays-Bas et le
M en 76 il y a 70 années en 2016 il y a
70 années j'avais l'impression que quand
ma mère s'est mise à té t moigné une
fois deux fois trois fois quatre fois
par semaine elle mettait toute sa vie
donc la nôre entre parenthèses c'était
pas la vraie vie donc j'étais hostile et
je sais pas quoi faire donc je joue
journaliste maman peux-tu me dire quand
est-ce que tu as dit à papa que tu avais
été déporté je ne m'en souviens pas ça
n'a pas d'importance et en fait ça en
avait pas et un jour j'ai compris par
une anecdote ma mère me parlant de de de
des vacances du fait qu'elle neavait pas
de sac à dos quand elle était petite
parce que le sac à dos c'était la
déportation pour ma grand-mère c'est
tabou pour vous Eveline le sac à dos je
comprends pardon que que que le livre pe
F
que si j'accepte la légitimité de sa
peur et que si elle accepte que j'aime
mon regard là-dessus et le livre est
devenu cela des discours parallèle mais
qui se ren compre ce que ça fait à une
famille la mémoire interdite impossible
et le traumatisme originel donc ça parle
de mon père ça parle de mon grand-père
qui était un type extraordinaire mais
qui a dû amener sa maman au train pour
sobybor où elle est morte parce qu'elle
n'avait pas contrairement eu la chance
d'avoir des faux papiers et et et et
tout ceci on ne sait jamais parler on a
vécu des souffrances des douleurs
parallèles sans jamais se rencontrer on
a à peu près réussi non ouais vous avez
réussi moi je trouve en tout cas c'est
le lecteur qui décide il a vraiment
fallu s'engueuler ah ça c'est sûr elle
se laisse pas faire alors elle est elle
genelle est parfois tumultueuse orageuse
votre relation en tout cas c'est un
magnifique livre force dingue sur sur la
mémoire sur l'oubli sur le mensonge
parfois aussi et je renvoie nos
téléspectateurs parfois le mensonge
permet la vérité et c'est passionnant de
d'être un peu lesé Mo d'une très belle
relation pleine d'amour avant tout merci
beaucoup Eveline askolovic vous restez
avec nous Claude c'est l'heure des
parties prix elles sont deux au féminin
pluriel vous allez pouvoir réagir
bienvenue aux affranchis on les
accueille tout de
suite bonsoir Cécilia Gabison agence ETX
et désormais la tribune dimanche alors
ETX magéan nous on a juste
accompagnéagche en tout cas journaliste
qui nous fait une chronique sur l'air du
temps on va commencer avec vous Bourbon
express de quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir
Elsa Mondin Gava je vais vous raconter
une histoire ce soir mais une histoire
dont tout le monde connaissait la fin je
sais c'est pas très vendeur mais je vais
pas vous mentir à l'Assemblée quand on
parle budget il y a aucun suspense ça
allaisse finir comme ça regardez
Elizabeth borne la première ministre qui
arrive Ivan an avion à la caméra était
bien concentrée puisque c'est furtif
elle rentre dans l'hémicycle
chorégraphie orchestrée elle a
l'habitude c'est le TR3 1 493 comme à
chaque fois que ce que ce sera
nécessaire j'agirai en conscience et
dans l'intérêt du pays et des
Français aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
voilà on connaît la mise en scène B est
bien orchestré même chose même
chorégraphie du côté des réactions des
des oppositions bah oui on aurait pu
tout écrire à l'avance les mêmes
chorégraphies ils viennent aux quatre
colonnes dénoncer le 493 surtout cette
fois-ci sa rapidité je vous rappelle que
le gouvernement l'a déclenché sans même
avoir commencé la discussion des
articles on est évidemment pas surpris
par le 493 mais il y a quand même une
surprise c'est que le gouvernement
innove même en matière de
493 parce que je crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché un 493 un jour sur un budget
avant même qu'on ait commencé l'examen
des articles ils ajoutent donc à la
méthode du 493 une méthode de fermeture
du débat uneerme une méthode du passage
en force et je ne crois pas que c'est
mauvais évidemment pour la démocratie
mais je ne crois pas qu'à long terme ça
soit très longtemps tenable comme forme
de gouvernement alors vous avez remarqué
quand même qu'il y a des petits
changements à la nupes normalement on a
le droit à une conférence de presse tous
ensemble regardez c'était l'année
dernière puisqu'on est à un an quasiment
jour pour jour du 1ier 493 là il sont
séparés ils viennent chacun leur tour on
verra ces dissensions pour les motions
la France insoumise avec la moitié des
communistes et la moitié des écologistes
ont signé une motion le PS ne l'a pas
signé mais la votera bon certains en
tout cas rien d'intéressant en fait dans
votre chronique tout été dit d'avance
j'ai bien cru aussi mirriam jusqu'au
dernier moment que ma chronique allait
manquer un peu de piquant mais il s'est
passé quand même quelque chose regardez
c'était quelques minutes après le 493
annoncé par la première ministre le
texte
sur madame la Première ministre
messieurs les ministres messieurs les
ministres messieurs les ministres je
n'ai pas fini la séance elle n'est pas
levée je vous remercie
ouais la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui fait la leçon à la
première ministre et au ministrees qui
eux étaient déjà qu partis prierz
d'aller se rassoir alors après
évidemment les caméras cétien les
députés présents nous ont dit he que yel
brun pivé elle est descendue de son
perchoir elle leur a fait la morale
pendant 10 minutes au ministre malpoli
qui préférait aller vite ailleurs que
dans cette hémicycle de 493 claudes
kovovic malpoli c'est une logique
politique on s'habitue au 493 c'est très
intéressant cette chronique oui c'est la
force de l'habitude non mais ce que je
dire c'est c'est la force de l'habitude
c'est une banalité la France depuis la
constitution du général de Gaulle n'a
plus de culture du débat parlementaire
elle n'a pas de culture du compromis
elle n'a pas une culture de majorité
elle n'a pas une culture de coalition
sinon Renaissance et les macronistes et
la droit sal peu importe d'ailleurs s li
avec qui il veulent donc du coup nous
avons une démocratie absolument formelle
on vote tout va très bien mais l'aspect
parlementaire n'existe plus du coup il
ne faut pas s'étonner si tous les
conflits finissent dans la rue dans la
violence dans des slogans dans une
incapacité de cette société de
s'entendre et de se confrontés parce que
ceux qui sont censés faire ce boulot
depuis qu'on a inventé le Parlement bah
sont nos députés qui ont son réduit un
rôle de figuration c'est extraordinaire
madame Bron Pivet elle est macronienne
autant qu'on peut être macronien ou
macroniste elle engueule son propre camp
parce qu'il tombe le masque il n ont
strictement rien à faire de ce passage
par le Parlement c'est un énorme
problème on le sait depuis montesqueieux
manifestement pourtant nous avons des
gens letttré au pouvoir ils ne l'ont pas
lu mais ça va continuer parce que c'est
la Constitution qui a voulu le général
de Gaulle et on n pas le droit d'y
toucher c'est ainsi mais c'est une
catastrophe bien c'est dit j'espère que
vous serez aussi en ver pour la
chronique de de Cécilia vous nous parlez
des des empathies sélectives selon selon
vous vous avez ressenti Cécilia avec
évidemment ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre en Israël et puis l'assassinat
du à race du professeur Dominique
Bernard oui en fait c'est que moi j'ai
ressenti des empathies sélective mais
j'ai l'impression que nous tous on a
ressenti ça qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire
par empathie sélective c'est d'un côté
de l'extrême bouleversement que l'on
ressent pour les uns et une indifférence
ou une quasi indifférence pour les
autres et c'est absolument sidérant et
notamment pour des gens qu'il se pensent
généreux d'être eux-mêmes cindés dans
leur empathie et ce qu'on a vu notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est d'un côté
des posts la surenchè de l'horreur on
vous en avait parlé avant le fait queil
fallille faire monter les les sortes de
chronomètre d'horreur pour pouvoir
quelque part raller les cœurs dans cette
espèce de bataille alors qu'en fait dans
cette concurrence des peines chacun de
son côté les gens sont bouleversés mais
seuls chacun de leur côté comme si il
n'y avait plus d'empathie commune comme
si on était obligé de choisir un camp et
qu'on ne ressentait même plus de peine
pour les autres cette cette
impossibilité de reconnaître l'au d'être
en empathie c'est pas nouveau la
polarisation finalement non c'est pas
nouveau et je dirais que là c'est c'est
c'est peut-être porté à un extrême
paroxisme et c'est très lié évidemment
aux réseaux sociaux parce que quelque
part les réseaux sociaux c'est le c'est
le commerce des émotions c'est vraiment
le la la nourriture du réseau social
c'est de l'émotion et donc on on partage
ces émotions avec des côtés très beaux
mais c'est aussi comme ça qu'on vient
chercher l'attention des gens donc ce ce
commerce de l'émotion nous amène à des
surenchères à chaque fois et en fait on
on est quelque part aujourd'hui
extrêmement solidaire avant il y avait
en journalisme vous connaissez peut-être
sa Miriam le mort kilométrique qui était
très cynique était on était plus
concerné par quelqu'un qui était mort à
côté chez vous en France que des morts
en Inde et aujourd'hui quelque part les
raisons ont aboli cette question de
distance mais pas la question de avec
qui je m'identifie et donc mais dans
cette concurrence des émotions sur les
réseaux les gens sont aussi complètement
littéralement essorés c'est un c'est un
orage émotionnel et qui conduit je pense
aujourd'hui à une forme de de carapace
alors je voudrais citer quand même
l'exemple de l'invasion du haut Caraba
et l'exode des armédiens qui redoutaient
une épuration ethnique et en fait ça a
suscité quelques indignations mais dans
le fond une grande indifférence et
l'assassinat du professeur Dominique
Bernard qui n'a pas non plus suscité la
grande honte d'émotion des réseaux
sociaux qu'on aurait pu attendre comme
si dans l'empathie était devenu un
archipel et que les fameuses bulles
d'information sont aussi en fait en fait
des bulles d'empathie et pour donner
exemp entre ces îosélo plus et pour vous
donner un exemple il y a quelques années
il y avait eu un sondage aux États-Unis
69 % des républicains américains
pensaient que les discriminations contre
les Blancs étaient aussi importante que
celle contre les Noirs c'estàdire on est
tellement replié sur ses propres
solidarité et empathie qu'on en perd
complètement la notion de l'autre et de
ce qui lui arrive ça ça va vous inspirer
alors mais j'ai un dernier allez-y TER
je P que l'empathie aujourd'hui c'est
c'est la mesure de de d'une sorte de
d'humanisme c'est la mesure de
l'humanisme et l'empathie c'est pas
l'affection on peut avoir de l'empathie
pour des gens pour lesquels on n'a pas
d'affection mais c'est bien la capacité
à considérer l'autre comme un égal et
j'aimerais revenir sur le dernier cours
de Samuel paatti vous savez qu'il
enseignant assassiné il y a 3 ans sa
sœur a choisi de donner lecture 7ette
semaines de son dernier cours et c'est
bouleversant car c'est un cours sur
l'exercice du dilemme pour que les
élèves développent leur capacité à juger
par eux-mêmes il leur a dit une liberté
peut entrer en conflit avec d'autres
droits ou avec le respect dû aux autres
personnes en parlant notamment de la
liberté de la presse et des caricature
mais ce qui nous permet de vivre
ensemble c'est l'empathie émotionnelle
c'était les mot de Samuel pay et cette
empathie émotionnelle c'est ce qui fait
que nous ne respectons pas autrui
uniquement parce que la loi nous y
oblige mais parce que nous le ressentons
comme faisant part de la même humanité
merci beaucoup Cécilien les réseaux
sociaux ont cassé notre capacité à
reconnaître l'autre à être en empathie
avec l'autre ou ça ça remonte à plus
loin les réseaux sociaux nê pas on en a
parlé tout à l'heure Eveline et moi vont
de la famille qui vit en Israël sa fille
ma sœur ses petits enfants mes neveux
mes niè et neveux
euh des familles qui sont massacrées
chez elles on sait ce que c'est ça nous
ressemble on y est énormément Eveline a
connu l'époque de l'après-guerre où dans
les Squire à Paris le fait d'avoir été
déporté ne disait pas grand grand chose
à grand monde aujourd'hui les déportés
sont au cœur
de la solidarité de notre histoire je
vais faire très simple
euh je vais faire très simple de la
aujourd'hui et mon vieux père qui n'est
plus de ce monde qui est un militant
sioniste et socialiste de gauche on
aurait rêvé les gens sont diapason de la
souffrance des Israéliens l'incapacité à
reconnaître comme des frères humains
comme des êtres qui souffrent comme des
enfants qui meurent comme des familles
qui sont également éradiqué l'incapacité
que nous avons d'individualiser les
morts palestiniens comme nous pouvons
individualiser les morts israéliens
parce qu'il nous notamment par les
réseaux sociaux est pour moi un énorme
problème en tant commme citoyen français
et en tant que juif également don la
famille la fille d'une notage du Hamas a
dit s'il vous plaît au nom de ma mère ne
détruisez pas Gaza elle a dit ça à
l'adresse de nitano merci beaucoup on
s'arrête là merci infiniment Eveline
askolovic Claude askolovic ce souvenir
ensemble c'est un très très beau texte à
piocher à lire tranquillement pour se
plonger dans dans une histoire familiale
la mémoire impossible un lien plein
d'amour un peu tourmenté parfois mais ça
vaut le coup très belle soirée
documentaire sur LCP à
[Musique]
demain